once a world-champion professional gamer
Hana song better known as diva joined
South Korea's mecha unit to pilot one of
their Mexican stack alhasan aamna cred
divas elite skills and fiercely
competitive spirit make her extremely
effective in her combat operations
whether fighting armed next near the
east china sea or demons in the nexus
diva never backs down and always placed
winner diva is a tenacious warrior who
bullies her enemies and forces them to
retreat ready for action diva straight
has two states neck mode and pilot mode
while in Mecca she has access to all of
her abilities and can attack while
moving her attacks also deal damage to
all enemies in front of her in pilot
mode diva becomes a fragile but deadly
ranged attacker she deals high damage to
single targets but can no longer attack
while moving her attacks also charge up
her ability to call down a new mech
bruisers are divas primary form of
mobility in neck mode activating this
ability greatly increases her movement
speed for a short duration enemies that
she runs into you while boosters are
engaged are damaged and knocked back
bruisers can be canceled early by
hitting the abilities key a second time
divas next mech mode ability is defense
matrix when activated diva projects a
field that significantly reduces the
damage of enemy heroes diva can move
world
matrix is active but she's locked facing
in its initial direction like Brewster's
defense matrix can also be cancelled
self-destruct is divas ability
activating it causes diva to bail out of
her mech which then explodes a short
time later dealing damage and knocking
back enemies in a large area this
ability has no cooldown but can only be
used when it has been fully charged
diva gains self-destruct charges by
taking damage and dealing damage when in
pilot mode divas the ability is call
mech which allows her to re-enter mech
mode once it is fully charged if her
mech is destroyed by an enemy
this ability starts a long cooldown that
is reduced by divas basic attacks call
mech is immediately available after
divas mech self-destructs divas first
heroic ability is bunnyhop
when activated divas mech becomes
unstoppable while dealing damage and
slowing all nearby enemies bunnyhop can
only be used in mech mode big shot
offers diva a powerful attack wall in
pilot mode she shoots a laser in a
straight line dealing damage to all
enemies in its path this ability has a
very short cooldown and it significantly
reduces call mechs cooldown for each
enemy hero it hits
Divac has two separate and distinct play
styles that depend on whether she's in
her mech Wallen mech mode diva has high
health and mobility allowing her to dive
in and bully the enemy team in pilot
mode diva deals high damage but has low
health attacking enemies will get her
back into her mech sooner but also puts
her at risk of dying diva automatically
enters pilot mode when her mech is
destroyed allowing her a chance to
escape keep in mind that this is divas
only form of survivability because she
can't use mounts in mech mode diva
relies on boosters to grant her the
mobility she needs to quickly get into
position boosters is a versatile ability
which can be used to traverse the
battlefield engage or escape from
enemies and chase down fleeing enemies
to finish them off Brewster's has a
short cooldown so don't hesitate to use
it when needed
self destruct forces enemies to either
evacuate a large area or suffer terrible
terrible damage launch her back forward
by using self-destruct while boosters is
active to turn it into a devastating
ranged attack diva can also cancel
boosters during self-destruct countdown
allowing her to place her mech precisely
where she wants it when playing against
diva use routes and stuns to prevent her
from escaping as you destroy her mech
and secure a kill destroying divas mech
only grants half the normal experience
so play aggressively in mech mode and
stay alive in pilot mode to deny XP to
the enemy team using defense matrix
forces the enemy team to choose between
dealing significantly reduced damage or
moving out of position diva can't attack
or use any other abilities while defense
matrix is active but you can move to
follow her opponents and keep them
within its area of effect bunnyhop is
best used to initiate a team fight after
boost
into the middle of the enemy team
because it slows enemies while dealing
damage it can also be used to catch and
eliminate escaping foes big shot gives
Deva a long range high damage poke in
pilot mode that can also get her back
into her mech much faster though it
can't be used in mech mode it can be a
deadly surprise the enemies who try to
capitalize on her vulnerability Deva is
an in-your-face disruptor who fearlessly
charges into battle and does whatever it
takes
for the win make sure to leave us a
comment and subscribe to heroes of the
storm on YouTube and around the web and
we'll see you in the Nexus vive moving
out